im kunst buchmarkt leuchtet ein verlag
besonders hell
für manche schon fast grell
der taschen verlag 1980 gegründet
flutete er seither den markt mit
preisgünstigen bildbänden von erotik
über populärkultur bis zu werken von
warhol oder klimt
viele große werke bedeutender künstler
welche früher nur in einem elitären
umfeld verbreitung fanden brachte
taschen zu kleinen preisen in den
mainstream buchhandel
er will ihn wüthrich und johannes willi
sind kunstliebhaber seit 2012 kuratieren
der künstler und die kunsthistorikerin
die international beachtete kunst
buchmesse ein maverick den erfolg von
taschen sehen sie darin begründet dass
der verlag das kunstbuch demokratisiert
hat doch taschen will mehr sein als die
ikea des kunst buchhandels
mit helmut newton hat der verlag im jahr
2000 erstmals ein kunstbuch im
xxl-format herausgebracht 464 seiten
dick und über 30 kilo schwer
aktuelles mammut buch ist die
collector's edition von annie leibowitz
476 seiten dick fast 40 kilo schwer und
je nach aufgabe zwischen 2700 und 5000
euro projekte irgendwo zwischen buch und
skulptur und werden gleich mit passendem
präsentierte stiegen fast den
gesellschaften in konsumgesellschaft und
produziert sich durch gesetz und
befriedigt das objekt vor uns meinte
andy und subkulturen wo schon seit
jahrzehnten publiziert und ehrlich oder
eben ihren ausspruch an kunst sozusagen
vom mittel in form von fans in selb
kopiert druckt post
so genanntes ins abgeleitet von magazins
sind bild publikationen in
kleinstauflagen die vernachlässigbaren
herstellungskosten erlauben es auch
unbekannten künstlern ihre werk zu
veröffentlichen
die sache ist so wie er plattform zum
ausdruck von wanda sticks oder nicht das
ist zum zeitpunkt von schumacher den usa
essenziell dass wichtiger wert oder
nicht aber grundsätzlich ist die
möglichkeit mit relativ bescheidenen
mittel sich spruch spruch verschafft
zins grenzen sich klar ab vom mainstream
definieren sich durch die freude
marginalen trotzdem können sie
stilbildend sein
dies zeigt dass laser mehr gesehen in
welchem der künstler beni bischof sein
schaffen seit 2005 mittels laser kopien
präsentiert die fangemeinde ist
gewachsen
dieses jahr erschien sein wildes
schaffen bei der edition patrick frey
der titel psycho es ist 25 kilogramm
schwer
600 seiten dick und präsentiert sich im
etablierten kunsthandel
buch oder sie in großauflage oder
einzelstück für die beiden organisatoren
der kunstmesse steht fest für die kunst
ist das papier als medium unabdingbar
spanien coolen spruch ist dasselbe
objekt ist oder sich zwischen objekt und
transportmittel für inhalt direkt so und
das ganze internet luft für eine frische
oder neuenburg und waadt und glaubt
daran
für das kunstbuch wird das licht deshalb
wohl nicht so schnell ausgehen